[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع على اندلاع القتال بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع وتحديدا في
السادس من مايو انطلقت اولام محطات مسار
جده التفاوضي بهدف انهاء الصراع بعد نجاح
جهود سعوديه امريكيه في جمع ممثلين عن
طرفي القتال لبدء محادثات مباشره بينهما
بعد اسبوع وقع ممثلا الجيش والدعم السريع
على ما عرف باعلان جده الذي تضمن التزاما
بحمايه المدنيين وبتمكين ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه وانسحاب القوات من المستشفيات
والعيادات والسماح بدفن الموتى باحترام
فضلا عن جدوله محادثات مباشره جديده بين
الطرفين في الرابع عشر من مايو انطلقت
الجوله الثانيه من مفاوضات جده بهدف
التوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار تزامنت
مع انتهاء الشهر الاول من القتال بين
الطرفين بعد باسبوع من المفاوضات جرى
التوصل لهدنه تمتد لسبعه ايام تبدا من
مساء الثاني والعشرين من مايو ووفق بيان
سعودي امريكي مشترك فان الجيش والدعم
السريع اتفقا ايضا على ايصال وتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه وتسهيل المرور الامن
لمقدمي لمساعدات الانسانيه وسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه في
التاسع والعشرين من مايو اتفق طرفها
القتال على تمديد اتفاق الهدنه لخمسه ايام
والاتفاق من جديد على حمايه المدنيين
وتمرير المساعدات الانسانيه اضافه الى
تعبيد الطريق للوصول لاتفاق وقف اطلاق نار
دائم بعد ذلك بيومين اعلن الجيش السوداني
تعليق مشاركته بمفاوضات جده وعزى ذلك الى
عدم التزام ما وصفها بالميليشيات المتمرده
ببنود الهدنه المتفق عليها